flames pour from an apartment in the
twin parks complex pictures shared on
the citizen app revealing the first
moments of what's become one of the
deadliest residential fires in modern
american history
in the three minutes it took fire crews
to reach the building they said the
smoke had reached every floor
they found victims on each one survivors
among them people who knew children who
died describe the horror and the
helplessness tomorrow is a school day
they're going to ask me why they are
friends
they're going to ask me tomorrow where
they are friends because then go
together then come back together what
i'm going to tell them tomorrow
the windows were blown out either by the
heat of the fire or residents desperate
for air smashing them it was a horrific
scene because you have to realize
besides being a firefighter you have to
deal with the mental stress of seeing
this carnage of what happened in the
bronx today
within hours investigators had
pinpointed the cause this fire began in
an apartment that spans two floors on
the second and third floor of the
building
it started in a malfunctioning electric
space heater
and because doors to that apartment and
a stairwell had been left open the fire
spread quickly with no external fire
escape the only way out was those
stairwells filled with smoke
we are indeed a city in shock
it's impossible to go into that room
where scorers of family
who are in such grief who are in pain
to see it in a mother's eyes as i held
her
who lost her entire family
it all happened days after 12 people
including eight children were killed in
a fire in a house in philadelphia its
thought smoke detectors there weren't
working
at the twin parks one resident said he'd
ignored the smoke alarm at first because
there have been so many false alarms
recently he soon realized like so many
that this one was horribly real greg
milam sky news